good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Thursday
happy Thursday everyone hey Jax how are
you I'm good knowing that it's Thursday
knowing that we're cruising downhill
into the latter half of the week it's
encouraging
it's encouraging ask me how I am how are
you
I'm
amazing I'm
would you like to share why I would
after months of uncertainty weeks of
agony
your girl has finally secured Taylor
Swift tickets for one of the shows I
said I wanted to go in Nashville because
like Nashville's iconic it's the weekend
of Margo's birthday we want it to go big
as of this morning this morning we got
our tickets now I'm still
got nothing for MetLife and my MetLife
seeds are the seats I want to be like
really close and see everything the
Nashville I don't really care but I'm oh
Living on a Prayer take my hand and
we'll make it off
yeah it's very exciting we got our ticks
the fam is going the fam is going I need
to you know plan my weekend plan my
outfits oh my God the same I thought it
was gonna be just one outfit
oh well yeah for your second Excursion
but no I just need one
but I'm not gonna get too hung up on it
like we're gonna be in a box with our
girlies yeah
it's a judgment-free zone no and like I
I wasn't sure everyone would be down
like when we started the group chat this
morning I'm like are we really doing
this and everyone was like yes yes can I
bring my husband can I bring my best
friend I'm like yeah the more people to
marry her like it brings the cost down
like please invite invite your neighbor
invite your accountant and by literally
the man who works at the bodega like
anyone can come as long as they're
paying oh yeah no this isn't a charity
oh no no like I'm so excited I cannot
believe like I just always having these
at Big Ideas you know and then like they
never happen and then like I'm sitting
at home and I'm like oh yeah this was
supposed to be the weekend I was gonna
go to Nashville but it's the year of yes
and we got it done yeah
so now we just got a plan now we gotta
plan like weekend in Nashville that's
also just like Baseline even without the
concert so exciting I love a girls
weekend in Nashville and the husbands
are coming like it's exciting yeah the
husbands are coming we were just talking
about that like I'm not sure because we
don't have space for everyone's husband
no not everyone's husband no it's gonna
be like a first hopefully hopefully
we're overwhelmed with people who want
to bring their you know friends and
husbands so that we really fill every
seat in the box and then everyone's cost
goes down and I feel like maybe this
would be a good opportunity to punish
Ben for what he did to you oh my god
that would be so mean consequences I
have been like the planner I secure like
I did everything and my husband doesn't
come that's so mean I could never do
that actions have consequences how will
he learn I would never he wouldn't even
learn like he would just hate me how are
you going to teach him everybody saw the
photo you posted it in the real he did
we posted the beans it was jarring and
people are not okay it's not sitting
well and we need a plan of action we
cannot let this go unpunished turdy
punishing myself like I would not be
like be having so much fun if like
everyone said with their husband like
Ben's at home because I'm being like
treating him like a child for sure but
we could also keep it a girly weekend
good well we should discuss it in the
chat we should discuss it in the chat
like most things it's a democracy Jackie
take it to the chat the box is a
democracy it's a democracy it's a box
yeah
um so that's just like a major update in
our lives which is the point of the show
yeah and considering all of the
turmoil about tickets in the past it's
good to share the good news as well yeah
and that you know the Swifty Community
could be happy for us I don't know that
they'll be happy because
the toaster Community will be happy for
us but the Swifty Community they'll
start you know with like well
they're not really deserving they're not
real fans Jackie said this one time on
the show it's every Swifty for
themselves in this life and you know
what I subscribe to that like you know
I'm I'm always looking out for number
one yeah the other 50s didn't get you
tickets
the toaster swifties every time I talk
about you know
um my lack of seats I've gotten a
million DMS from people like I have an
extra seat in Houston Tampa it's never
been like a city I plan to go to if
somebody literally said MetLife like I'm
there yeah I was invited to Tampa oh you
by the way I was actually thinking you
should go to Tampa it's far it's really
far and the drive from like Tampa to
South Florida is one long dark highway I
think they call it like crocodile alley
or something I drove it in the middle of
the night and I almost ran out of gas
when I was in Clearwater for my show and
then heading to Fort Lauderdale after my
show I was like oh it's a three hour
drive let's not spend the night in
Clearwater let's just drive she was
wrong literally we had no gas left we're
driving on this forlorn endless pitch
black Highway nothing in sight nothing
in sight it's um
it's a reservation like land so it's
just these miles and miles of forest
like that's it it's like a little scary
it's dark there's no civilization thank
God literally like I think we had maybe
like 10 or 20 miles left in our gas tank
that there was uh actually quite lovely
gorgeous brand new gas station with like
snacks and we got gas and I felt you
know it's like a mirage I'm like this
isn't a real gas station it's it's my
eyes playing tricks on me but if I
didn't see that gas station like I might
not be here today no you would just like
have parks on the side of the road wait
until morning AAA would come you'd still
get it that's that's just like the
beginning of every cautionary tale they
ran out of gas you were with a big group
no it was just me and one other person
really I thought that that was the show
that family went to no no no they came
to Fort Lauderdale
but nobody made the trip to Clearwater
so it was me and Lizzy one other woman
uh-oh on the side of the roomless women
that's how every story starts they
pulled over for help never seen again oh
yeah goodbye turdy Lou Goodbye turdy Lou
thank you good day Journey Lou no like
ever I feel like this happens to
everyone like they have a few stories in
their life where like in hindsight they
realize like how close they were to
potential danger yes that happens to me
a lot and like those stories keep me up
at night like how I could be so
irresponsible not get gas but I didn't
know that we're about to embark on this
it's like a famous Highway it never ends
and there's nothing on it great so I
won't be going to the Tampa show is what
you're saying so if you're making the
journey to Tampa from South Florida like
Miami Fort Lauderdale you have to take
that Highway and just know be prepared
bring snacks have a full tank yeah
do it during the day like it was just
good tips for a road trip anyway yeah I
guess but like with road trips it's like
getting gas is all part of the fun you
know except when you drive with me and I
flush our keys down the toilet by
accident we end up stranded in
Connecticut but that was just like a me
thing there's worse places to be than
Connecticut but still no it was broad
daylight still it was broad daylight we
are like a very busy uh Highway and a
very busy rest stop like I didn't feel
scared I felt [__] annoyed annoyed oh
my God like that was one of the worst
days of my life so grateful that the car
was unlocked and we could get our stuff
I just also another like added layer of
that story is when we woke up that
morning in Rhode Island to make our
journey home my like throat was starting
to hurt and I might have just been like
hungover and tired but like you know it
was during those times when you just
like felt like you had coveted and I was
like sitting there just like let me get
home like I feel like I might have covid
and like I'm getting everyone sick I
didn't have Kobe but that one I was like
already not feeling well and then we're
making such good time on that I'm
driving like an animal like so fast it's
like a four or five hour drive I was
getting us there in literally three and
a half I was making sickening time we
stopped to take a piss get a snack I'm
peeing the car keys fall in the toilet
I'm like oh my God I'm gonna have to
stick my hand in this toilet next thing
I know automatic flush my day was
[__] ruined that we have an episode
um a podcast episode about it what was I
think the podcast episode was called
extremely flush if you're new here it's
one of our best episodes telling the
story
um go enjoy check that out it's a crazy
story oh look at you rubbing your belly
I know it's a big belly
me too but at least you have like a
reason
yours isn't so big
no actually I still have like a pretty
big Valley
[Laughter]
and like not really we also have that
Olive shirt yesterday thanks Selena yeah
I was wearing like a skin tight shirt
yesterday which I do not do and some of
you might notice my arms were in front
of my stomach the entire time and my my
legs were crossed my knee was so high up
just to cover my stomach lady Tings no
just like life things oh my God and
that's why you look like a lady I am a
lady
you're a lad oh
so true
she read me to filth but like can you be
mad when it's true no no no or when it's
just like so Punchy you can't be yeah
you can't no you can't be mad when
somebody like makes a joke at your
expense but it's such a good joke it's
like you want to be offended but you're
overwhelmed by the feeling of respect
respect for the person's joke yeah
that's the way to do it that's way to do
it you have to respect women in comedy
that's the truth so we've got a good
show because last night was Vanderpump
Rules and I have never really seen an
episode of TV that made me feel so many
things and you would think it would be
because of what's you know gone on in
the last couple of weeks with Scandal
but like honestly it has my feelings
have nothing to do with scandals no we
have to judge the episode on its face
and it's actually surprising what
conclusions You Come Away with
it's surprising with what conclusions
You Come Away with and I actually can't
recall in recent memory an episode of
any show reality where a person came off
as bad as Lala Kent did in last night's
episode it might be one of the worst
episodes for any reality star in history
I Concur and you know I'm a huge Lala
girl I know like this is not a great
season for her no I can't wait to dive
into it and I'm sure we have Savannah
Pub news too because already
Vanderpump will go into TV recap we'll
have to watch what happens live also
so without further Ado let's get into
the past five stories that you need to
know why the hell not why the hell not
today's episode is brought to you by
State Farm the State Farm personal price
plan helps you create a plan that gives
you options so you get an affordable
price and it comes with a lot of
benefits like the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and an affordable price that's
just for you because after all life is
just better when you can personalize
your experiences you know like the
Taylor Swift concert we're making it our
own we're always saying how important
and personal certain things in life are
Taylor Swift tickets Taylor Swift
playlists I mean for me it's always
going to be ever more over folklore
um personalization just gives you your
power
and personalization means you have the
power to choose what you want to include
and what you want to leave out it just
feels better that way and why shouldn't
insurance work like that too so true
like you know Jax and I always say we're
carbon copies of each other we're so
similar but even our insurance so
personal be so different you know you
have a home we are different even though
you're a Tesla I have a Tesla I have a
home like I need a different insurance
plan than your girlie over there it's so
true and that's what the State State
Farm personal price plan is all about
you can choose to include options like
bundling your home and auto policies and
that means you'll get the coverage you
want at an affordable price just for you
in the end you'll have a policy that
gives you what you want what's better
than that like a good neighbor State
Farm is there
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary again today's
episode is sponsored by the State Farm
personal price plan today's episode is
also brought to you by kitch 2023 is the
year of good feel good do good be good
to yourself Kitsch makes feeling good
simple with luxurious game changing
Essentials that beauty enthusiasts swear
by so whatever your budget whatever your
skin type whatever your hair type Kitsch
believes that you deserve little
indulgences at affordable prices morning
noon and night it was started in 2010 by
selling hair ties door-to-door just a
hustle and a dream kitchen is a
self-funded female founded and now
carried in over 20 000 retail locations
business their best sellers include
satin pillowcases satin caps and eye
masks so their satin is vegan and
cruelty free they are so good for your
hair and your skin while you sleep if
you wake up in the morning with like a
full-blown Rat's Nest and it's like the
blowout you got the day before it
doesn't even exist try sleeping in a um
satin cap it has changed my life or
sleeping with a satin pillowcase they
have both and they're so good they also
have shampoo and conditioner bars which
are part of bottle free Beauty you don't
have to you know keep restocking on
plastic bottles of shampoo and
conditioner use their bars they last
longer and they're great for the
environment and their heatless satin
curling rollers so you can say goodbye
to heat damage they are Tick-Tock videos
of people throwing away their 600
curlers for this item it's amazing and
it's only a fraction of the price it's
18 right now kitchen is offering you 30
off your entire order at mykitch.com
toast that's right 30 off anything and
everything at my kitchen
toast one last time that's mykitch.com
t-o-a-s-t that'll get you 30 off your
order for all of your skin and hair care
needs from a trusted brand like Kitsch
thank you turdy Lou you're welcome
Jackie O
our first story
eyebrow gate explained Kylie Cosmetics
announced this morning that they have
their new Kai lash mascara dropping
imminently which answers a lot of
people's dumb [__] questions about
why Kylie and Haley were showing their
eyebrows were they making fun of Selena
mm-hmm
[Music]
oh and I [__] told you yeah I feel
really good about where we landed on
this
um you had the inclination that she was
launching a mascara I did not but you
know even if you didn't know that like I
just think it's so important not to
assume the worst in people there is a
Bible verse have they done always give
people the benefit of the doubt so if
you're natural like inclination is just
to be like oh they were making fun of
Selena like sun is a victim I'm like I
need to defensively and I need to bully
Haley and Kylie like maybe you should
look inward in this moment because you
were wrong you look like clowns
um and let's just not always like jump
to conclusions now a lot of people who
have seen this are offering rebuttals
just to kind of justify their bullying
of these young women they say one Kylie
and Chris definitely just decided to
launch it yeah that's how big business
Works they just decided to launch a
mascara to prove that there was
something just to save face now
formulating a product packaging takes
months getting a trademark what's the
name of the Wisconsin eyelash right I
believe you could look it up she's had
the mascara for about uh the trademark
excuse me for a very long time so that
line of thinking is just ill-informed
and silly and again you look like clowns
no and also one month ago Kylie posted
before the things with Haley she posted
a carousel on her Instagram of her eyes
where she's wearing heavy mascara she
literally has a mascara wand on her
eyelash and the caption is new Kylie
Cosmetics coming soon like I'm sorry it
doesn't take Albert Einstein to put
together that she's dropping a mascara
but even Albert Einstein would know that
she is dropping a mascara of course and
then the other the other you know line
of thinking people rebutting this saying
well you know this is actually I don't
believe that they were promoting the
mascara because this FaceTime photo like
Haley's lashes look bad and she doesn't
even look like she's wearing mascara I
don't think they were trying to show
that Haley was wearing the mascara
they're just trying to show like ah he's
like something's coming for the eyes was
it a FaceTime photo that made the it was
like yeah it was a screenshot of a
FaceTime where they're both showing
their eyes so Kylie's um
up close with her eyes she's definitely
wearing mascara and Haley is not you can
go to my Instagram I have a screenshot
right there oh you do okay
um I want to see exactly what was posted
oh I see because I thought that maybe
Kylie and Haley were doing one of their
videos together for Kylie's YouTube
channel or for Haley's bathroom I mean
or both I thought that that's what they
were doing I thought they were together
and yeah um that Kylie and Haley were
filming one of Kylie's like get ready
with me using our new kailash and that's
why they were posting it
also maybe this that's a great idea I
hope that they do do that yeah they
should run and do one now and also uh in
my bathroom with Haley I just think like
we really as a society need to take a
look inward into how you know you all
acted these last couple of weeks like
the Relentless they really let up on
Kylie because Selena commented like no I
love Kylie no because they live for they
only are interested in Haley and Selena
right so
they really
and still I still see all over my Tick
Tock and my Twitter and my Instagram
Relentless bullying saying Haley Bieber
looks like an ear like making fun of her
her business her looks her family like
my God all for what a mascara now that's
what you all did like I seriously I I
think this is a teachable moment for
people I and I know they won't because
the internet never learns but everyone
who engaged in this type of you know
online harassment and bullying like I
really hope you take a look inward to
see how [__] stupid and mean you are
they won't especially if they're still
justifying it so let me get this right
the things that were posted that meant
that Haley and Kylie were making fun of
Selena the eyes Face Time right and then
I had done a tick tock Selena had done a
tick tock like a week before like
showing her makeup yes she was like
zoomed in on her eyebrows she overly
laminated her eyebrows and said I
accidentally overlay that oh yeah yeah
yeah
um so they had their eyes just add Haley
Bieber and then a picture of Kylie close
up that says this was an accident so
between the word accident and the fact
that there was an eye and an eyebrow
this is you know bullying
um but the reason why I thought they
were making a video is because when
Kylie posted this as an accident
question mark it's in front of her pink
yeah backdrop where she does her YouTube
videos maybe there is a video coming to
support the launch of this mascara yeah
and maybe Haley is lending her celebrity
to Kylie's cause we don't know but even
still at these these people are crazy
and they will never concede that they
were wrong no and they're crazy and it's
easy to just you know
dismiss them but when you think about
like the real implications like look
Hayley Bieber has definitely seen all of
what people are saying about her like
this is a human being and it went beyond
just like funny meme internet culture
like it went to really dark mean places
and I think it's wrong and I don't I
don't us you know uh what's the word I'm
looking for I don't um
what's the word I'm looking here for
what are you trying to say it's not
associate but like I don't relate to my
generation and of the internet in this
way at all yeah and you know when you
think about who the Jelena stands are
like these are people our age because we
were we were young yes we think Jelena
stands are like 12. but we were 12 when
they were Jelena and now we're all grown
up so these are grown ass women no
chelina's stanhood is definitely a
mental illness I agree there's also like
the people who just like keep talking
about this story like you know
commentators and that I'm sure like on
Tick Tock it's like explainer channels
they have Credence to these actual
conspiracy theories hallucinations
hallucinations yes there's that and then
there's also Selena who fed into this
thing the entire time and if the entire
time she never said a peep about instead
of playing a victim it wouldn't have
that's just like gasoline on the fire
for the people who will do anything to
help Selena and to get attention from
Selena yeah oh so you know we'll comment
in my video if I'm really feeling sorry
for her and like destroying to other
women yeah no I play there is she Bears
responsibility and I she does I'm sorry
yeah she does
this is so this got so out of control
and it's still going on it's not even
like it's still going on Justin Bieber
performed at a festival and they were
chanting like [__] Haley in the crowds
it's like oh you're taking this [__]
into real life you're not embarrassed
another level of mental illness yeah
yeah this was such a terror honestly it
gives me a pit such look what the
internet can do so fast with no proof no
nothing
my God imagine if people put their
energy toward worthy causes
or we would be we would be a perfect
Society or toward their own lives maybe
they would be healed their own lives
maybe they would be healed turdy Lou
maybe they would be healed turdy low but
maybe not maybe not
this is just like a very upsetting Saga
series of events yeah but I do I'm never
even if even it is you know people feel
Justified and rightfully so I'm just
never gonna be the type of person to
like hop on a bandwagon and like start
destroying people like even with this
Raquel thing it's crazy and I'm like
eating it up but like people are calling
her like even Chloe Feynman called her a
filthy [__] on watch weapons live like
it was kind of crazy
um and and you know she she's in the
wrong Raquel like there is justifiable
anger towards her I'm just personally
never gonna be the type of person like
hop on a bandwagon of Internet culture
and now
to see how wrong everyone was like
there's no repercussions for that sort
of behavior because it's Anonymous
internet activity yeah
it's terrible yeah Ariel Tardis you have
to like keep it in mind that these are
people and I know this Raquel think it's
just like on another level yeah
and what she did was so wrong so people
really do feel so Justified because it's
like well she's in the wrong and I'm in
the right but it's like get your own
life I know like I like
it reminds me a lot of the Ariel
charnising like how everyone got so bent
out of shape people's literally saying I
was at Polo Bar I saw Brandon charnis
getting arrested there's no
accountability when [__] like that ends
up being completely untrue yeah
that's different but yeah yeah it's just
like the whole message of like internet
culture having no accountability and
these things just happen and they have
real life repercussions and then things
just move on and people never get their
Justice yeah it's like it's so unfair
you know they get their Justice like 15
years later when nobody gets back on old
clips you know just like with like all
those old interviews of like Lindsay I
can't believe that's the way we treated
young girls look how you're treating
Haley Bieber like what's the difference
she's so right she's so right
what's the difference
just you know new clothes yeah
same outfit yeah your clothes
so true are you ready for our next story
someone who's always trying to batter
themselves always being knocked down
along the way though will never stop her
who when it's Paltrow oh I have so many
thoughts reveals the weirdest Wellness
Trends she's tried and she's getting a
lot of backlash for her habits Gwyneth
has done some of the wackiest things in
the name of Wellness but the weirdest
one according to her apparently involved
her rectum during an appearance on the
art of being well podcast she which we
love a deer media podcast Making Waves
love she revealed that she has used
ozone therapy rectally it's pretty weird
but it's been very helpful according to
Healthline ozone therapy refers to the
process of administering Ozone gas into
your body to treat a disease or wound
however the process is not regulated in
2019 the FDA claimed it was a toxic gas
with no known useful medical application
the FDA also claimed that Oxycontin was
not addicted and less than one percent
of patients get addicted which is
important to know the FDA claims a lot
of stuff oh
oh no [__] lies were
[__] told [__] how can we
trust Hefty after release after we've
seen Dope Sick no and it's not just the
one thing like oh oh
got him got him Gwyn has went on to
break down her Wellness routine with the
host will Cole all while admitting
administering herself in IV she said I
love an IV I'm an early IV adopter
noting that she specifically loves two
types of IV drips I can't pronounce them
she said they're quite hard to find and
those make me feel so good aside from
that she said she practices intermittent
fasting until around noon when she
finally eats something that won't Spike
her blood sugar like soup or bone broth
then she gets in one hour of movement
from Pilates or walking before starting
her post-workout routine after dry
Brushing in her infrared sauna for 30
minutes she has a Paleo dinner with lots
of vegetables to support her detox
so the backlash she's receiving is not
really about the ozone therapy it's
about eating bone broth as a meal yes
it's about doing Tracy Anderson and uh
paleo following paleo restrictions or
whatever and basically they say starving
herself what are you detoxing if you're
only having ever like bone broth and
vegetables and the the backlash has
basically been this isn't Wellness this
is a toxic diet culture so I just want
to know and I I'm ready for everyone to
disagree with me this is going to be a
hot take unpopular opinion why the [__]
do you care sure let's say some of the
stuff she's doing is toxic diet culture
even though I don't think
um
because she chooses to do Tracy Anderson
like that makes it toxic diet culture
like doing a soul cycle is not toxically
Tracy Anderson it's just it's just like
a trendy you know workout I like it's
considered toxic diet culture isn't she
just like bopping around yeah no because
it's a workout oh because we're working
out is toxic yeah like
who [__] cares Gwyneth Paltrow did
not get on this podcast and say this is
what everyone should do and you're all
fat slobs if you don't she was asked
what she does and this is what she does
you don't like it don't do it don't
listen to the podcast like the way this
has blown up and you know who actually
had a very good take and I don't think
I've said these words in a while Bethany
Frankel she's you know she's always
making takes on Tick Tock and they're
making waves she was like literally who
[__]
yeah and then there's the argument like
what is this saying for girls
so you know what do you have a daughter
tell her not to watch this you teach her
differently it's not but it's pastor's
job to teach your children anything it's
your job [__] yours yeah I would also
say that one Gwyneth Paltrow is is like
a guinea pig for wellness I think she
tries all these things that she can be
an expert on that for her saying I'm
sure she's tried a lot of stuff that
didn't work or do anything and doesn't
write about but then she's done things
that she then espouses like vaginal
steaming and some of the other
quirkier things but like that's her
business and that's her brand I also
would say the proof is in the pudding
like this woman looks amazing and she's
one of the few people in Hollywood who's
letting herself age naturally and the
only thing that she's doing that's
anti-aging are these natural remedies
that yes seem extreme to you but like
what you'd rather just having her
injecting herself full of chemicals
that's not extreme like it's everyone
does has some sort of regimen that they
follow I think Gwyneth looks amazing
she's clearly extremely healthy like I'm
not saying this is for everyone also not
everyone can afford to do this has the
time to spend their whole day worried
about Wellness what they're putting into
their body and how their body is like
physically moving but that is actually
her job her business yeah by the way you
are just like straight facts today Jax
Jacks with the facts Jax with the facts
and like there are all different kinds
of Lifestyles that are promoted on
podcasts on tick tock on Instagram
everybody finds their beat like there
are people for whom this is for
by the way that's so true I feel like
there's a lot of discourse around like
body positivity and like you know
accepting all all sizes and I love that
but it's obviously on the heavier
Spectrum yes but really at its Core Body
positivity is accepting all bodies and
all Lifestyles so why is while yes you
know she's extreme on the other end why
is that not acceptable right that's a
good point and even if you just take
like one I mean not that you need to
take anything from her interview but
even if you were just like maybe I've
been interfa intermittent fasting maybe
I should then break my fast with
something that won't inspect my blood
sugar I would never have thought I would
have been like Bagel yeah right sugar
you don't have to then spend your whole
day intermittent fast bone broth Tracy
Anderson a Paleo dinner like she's doing
all these things to give recommendations
to her audience which by the way there
is an audience for this
if you follow Gwyneth Paltrow on social
media which I do and it's one of my
favorite pastimes
um she is always cooking like she eats
and it's obviously not anything I would
ever eat it's like grains and veggies
and eggs and
she cooks and eats a lot like I don't
think this is a malnourished human being
yes it sounds extreme but she was
literally asked what are things that you
do for this was the question and again
she didn't endorse anything for anyone
else it's just that's it's just so crazy
to like ask someone a question and then
like attack them for their own
they're not hurting anyone yeah well
it's not like the interview attacked her
no but like your habits are wrong but
but you tuned into it no and like if she
clearly has such a big feeling she has
such a big business she was just on
Shark Tank like to act like she doesn't
know a little bit what she's talking
about and that she's just like this
Fringe person starving herself and
that's just not the case
yeah no I think everybody really needs
to relax I'm not into this attack on on
people's lifestyle when it comes to diet
and I'm not a person who's ever been
particularly fond of diets but like it's
People's Choice like that everyone is
just trying to better themselves and no
one has all the answers really when
someone's not trying to better
themselves okay like you want to go like
shoot up crack I don't care like what is
this mentality of people being so
obsessed with other people's choices
like that's never gonna be me ever like
That's My Philosophy for everything like
you're doing something to yourself and
I would never do it live your life
bestie like I am never going to get so
bent out of shape about what someone
else is doing what someone else's choice
that doesn't affect me yeah I will never
care I will never care
get a life
yeah focus on you she also winds up
being really on The Cutting Edge of
stuff so sure I would maybe take heed
but no like even like like the I mean
vaginal steaming I don't know where
that's gone but I remember like she had
her show on Netflix and she was talking
about like the Wim Hof method where it's
like a cold plunge you see everyone with
a [__] ice bath in their backyard now
that they get at Home Depot 100
no and she talked about this on Shark
Tank she was like years maybe 10 years
ago like they were writing on the blog
about gluten-free and people were like
that's so crazy that's so crazy that's
so crazy now you literally can't walk
into a grocery store without being
attacked by gluten-free products I know
and now it's all about grain free she
said and by the way that's not to say
everything she talks about is good
anything and we have to give her a
little bit of respect for sure and I
just don't feel like like I don't
understand why if I don't have a gluten
intolerance I need to be gluten-free no
no one's properly explained that to me
no I also feel like people who are
gluten-free like are fine like they're
actually not like man some people make
it for health choices like sure love
that but people are saying they have a
gluten intolerance when like their whole
life they were completely fine um yeah I
grew up on like peanut butter jelly
sandwiches right Celiac is different
like even actual medical like uh
intolerance like I get that but people
who just like make up that they're
gluten-free like okay I just feel like
it's people trying to be interesting
yeah or a healthy but I don't I don't
understand maybe there are health
benefits they haven't been communicated
to me well enough in order for me to be
convinced because you know I'm always
open to bettering myself I am turning
this you are I am and why can't I have a
grain what's wrong with grains you know
what actually I you know obviously I
feel like for a lot of us like the
millennial kind of
Gwyneth Paltrow Vibe is Lauren Bostic
like she's always sharing wellness and I
took a wellness tip from her and it has
changed my life it's like so dumb and
it's not like anything actually like I
don't even know if you could be
considered Wellness but I bought a
tongue scraper
that sounds Wellness Jackie you have to
get one wait why what does it do when I
brush my teeth in the morning I also
just scrape my tongue with your
toothbrush no with a tongue scraper okay
and I have brushed my tongue with a
toothbrush many many times over my life
you would die if you saw the stuff that
comes out of my tongue in the morning
it's like so much phlegm where do you
get it Amazon Amazon it's
um I tell you I feel different
and you know I'm always telling you like
I'm waking up with a sore throat like
whatever I feel different I scrape my
tongue before bed and after I wake up
change my life shout out Lauren Bostick
like legitimately was there a specific
brand Amazon like it's a metal like it's
a letter U yeah okay okay I see I'll go
with the best seller and I get your
[__] hard Jackie you will die the
more the ones at night aren't that crazy
in the morning I cannot
get over and I feel like I've noticed a
big difference in my breath that's what
the the title says bad breath reduce yes
great girls and how much is it it's like
10 bucks on Amazon it's not expensive
yeah I it's already ordered one second
it is I think it was like nine guys
scrape your [__] tongues like
it's disgusting
especially if you've had like breath
problems scrape your tongue it's the
best thing I ever did that's Wellness
for sure yeah no and so now I'm like
maybe I need to get into Wellness I feel
Weller maybe I should be taping my mouth
I should be taping my mouth I've also
started to take magnesium before bed I
take magnesium every day as well that's
like a Ben Soffer thing that he's been
very into Wellness weirdly and I'm
always like yeah those beans are
extremely well no Ben is like always
looking into like Eastern medicine like
things he could do to like but I feel
like he's also Ben loves a quick fix
yes but weirdly know when it comes to
his body like he's always looking for
like Alternatives and he's been like on
my ass about magnesium when I tell you
I've taken magnesium before bed every
day this week what's it doing for you
first of all I'm having a much more
restful sleep I am waking up on my own
and I find my thoughts to be slightly
calmed before bed you know I'm always
thinking about like crazy [__] before
bed interesting I take it for pregnancy
migraines and it's all headaches good
for um
I think leg cramps yeah well I've been
told to take magnesium for my leg cramps
um and I've gotten magnesium when I've
done IVs for like hangovers I've gotten
ones with magnesium and it makes me so
tired and the nurse one time actually
told me magnesium can make you tired so
it's also good to take before bed well I
do happen to take my vitamins before bed
so that so I'm just like kind of on a
wellness Journey on a wellness journey I
mean I'm on a wellness Journey too in
part two of my video collab with flave
city is up today we went shopping
together for baby food and I just like
picked out what I would buy at the store
and he told me what was wrong with it
and went to get instead or if I was
making the right choices they're on my
Instagram and Flav cities Instagram and
people are quaking like I'm a Bobby
approved girly well I would also like to
know 100 of the time for me like the
wellness things I've been doing are like
very low lift like I'm not going to get
a cold plunge I'm not gonna get a dry
brush
um so if anyone has any like dry brush
sounds low lift I don't know hovered
over naked in the shower sounds like a
lot of backwards I think you could like
you could just dry brush your face
okay well if anybody has like low lift
Wellness things like I've really made an
impact like for me like the
toothbrushing scraping has made a real
impact and it's three seconds of my day
and it was like a 10 thing on Amazon any
low lift Wellness tips that'll just make
me feel better especially like during
the week in the mornings let me know
okay
I'm kind of like loving that sterning I
know we're we're just constantly
evolving turdy Lou I know because if
like a year ago me heard me talking like
this she would slap me in the face I
know add Wellness to the list Downton
reading Wellness what was the other
thing wearing your hair hair up hair up
that's a wellness tip it is are you
ready for our next story a little drama
a little movie Set drama because Cameron
Diaz is working on her comeback film and
allegedly Jamie Foxx is throwing it into
chaos as he sacked four crew members and
is just having a total quote meltdown
well this is the first time hearing of a
Cameron Diaz comeback and for that I'm
excited exactly Cameron Diaz's first
film in nine years has reportedly been
thrown into chaos after co-star Jamie
Foxx's onset meltdown it's been reported
that the actor has become so unhappy
with production on the London set of
back in Action that's the movie so that
four people have been sacked the Netflix
comedy will Mark Cameron's return to
acting after previously stepping from
the spotlight stepping away from the
spotlight to raise her son according to
the Sun the Oscar winner Jamie Foxx has
axed an executive producer two directors
and even his own driver becoming pretty
unpopular in the process A source told
the publication there have been some
major issues on set and Jaime has had a
major meltdown over it all
by the way just like
Cameron Diaz and Jamie Foxx working
together again after Annie again after
Annie they also worked together in 1999
for the movie Any Given Sunday so they
obviously like working together yeah and
I feel like Cameron Diaz is like really
down to earth and she wouldn't like
gravitate towards someone who's like
mean and difficult to work with so I
don't know there's something about the
story sound adding up for me yeah
he I don't know
I don't know what's going on but I need
this movie and I need it now so
everyone's trying to find a way to work
together do we have a synopsis is it
like a rom-com Jamie and Cameron fall in
love back in Action sounds like a like
an action movie like it kind of is so it
will be directed by Horrible Bosses
director and written by the neighbor's
screenwriter it's been filming in London
since December little is known about the
plot but the actors haven't spotted
filming spotted filming stunts so that
gives action on the River Thames
alongside their co-star Glenn Close
oh wow yeah this doesn't sound like a
classic Cameron film no but she's always
switching it up I know and she's always
right
she has a good picker even though I do
think that like a lot of celebrities
make bad movies when they work with
Netflix just because Netflix pays them a
lot of money yeah but she is not coming
out of retirement to embarrass herself
yeah and she doesn't need the money lets
me not forget she made 100 million
dollars on Shrek yeah but I think that
it's possible to make good movies with
Netflix
it's possible but I think they start to
get bad when you have like a multi-movie
deal and then by like movie four we're
like what are we saying now but yeah but
first movie back in nine years there's a
lot of story to tell there is whenever I
hear that Netflix is making a movie even
with the Nancy Meyer thing we were
talking about yesterday I'm always just
like certain it's not gonna be good
Netflix like original movies are really
not known to be amazing some of them
have been great yeah of course but some
of them like with big stars I feel like
they're always getting like Mark
Wahlberg Kevin Hart The Rock like and
they're like I couldn't even tell you
the names
yeah they're all pretty forgettable
they're not bad I watch them I enjoy
them and I look forward that they're
coming to Netflix but they don't stick
with you they're almost like Hallmark
but with like bigger budgets and
celebrities they make like the same
movies yeah they're like rom-coms it
used to just be like the stuff that we
would go to the movies and see like
crappy movies but I guess there's just
more of them now yeah hmm well I will be
watching this movie because I'm a
Cameron Diaz girly and I think her and
Jamie Foxx have great on screen
chemistry of course but I don't know if
I'm buying this this drama like maybe
it's just I don't know it just doesn't
sound
just doesn't sound right to me yeah
there's got to be more to the story yeah
are you ready for our next story is it
our fifth and final no it's our fourth
okay one of your favorite least favorite
people I could give you a million
guesses and you never would guess one of
my favorite least favorite yeah okay
I'll give you a few I'll give you a few
Clues reality TV
a show on Netflix Chris Shell no close
your least favorite person on that show
Mary
Mary Fitzgerald was worried when Brie
TSC joined selling Sunset so Nick
Cannon's baby mama Bree TSC is joining
the new season of selling Sunset Mary
spoke to design scene in an interview
and said I was a little worried when she
first came I was like I can't do any
more drama please don't give me any more
drama but she said uh Mary right like
that's literally the [__] your job
that's your job
um she said that Brie ended up being
nice and that she likes her a lot and
there will be a very interesting Dynamic
on the forthcoming season I kind of love
that they have like another celebrity
adjacent person like Rochelle was Justin
Hartley's ex yeah um I kind of like that
I did see also an article that was you
know unverified sources that you know
Christine is obviously off the show and
Chris Shell is the new villain
huh in my eyes she always was the
villain agreed so for everyone to see
what I see if that's you know
potentially happening I'm on board I too
am on board I don't think I have the
patience to catch up on the show because
it's really bad and slow I didn't even
finish the most recent season it was
really bad I didn't start the most
recent season and to you will watch like
10 hours of content to just find out
that like you know Christine and Emma
dated the same guy 20 years ago I'm I'm
good on that
um so unfortunately it's not for me but
I'm glad that you know
they're keeping it interesting yeah this
is a good casting if I was still into
the show I would watch but it got really
bad the first season was amazing the
second season was great and then after
that it was just bad and I'm sorry there
is no show without Christine no
like try as you might may you can do the
most constantly but she was the show and
I loved her but whether you hated her or
loved her you could admit she was the
show yeah
so they're just gonna have to you know
they've made their bed now they lie in
it Mary are you ready for our fifth and
final story if it is the fifth and final
story that's brought to you by manscaped
ladies this is a public service
announcement our friends at manscapes
now have beard products that are going
even further with their brand new weed
whacker 2.0 tell the world the leaders
in below the waist grooming are
traveling north of your man's South Pole
their nose hairs are a major turn off
and the new weed whacker 2.0 and their
new beard line confirms they have the
best tools for his hygiene too time for
you to upgrade his game by going to
manscaped.com and use code toast for 20
off plus free shipping so meet the beard
hedger Pro kit it is the ultimate
package that makes it easier than ever
for the man in your life to craft his
signature look it starts with the beard
hedger which is the only beard trimmer
he'll need it has a titanium coated
t-blade it is tough on hair but smooth
on his face it's waterproof cordless has
a rotary wheel and it has over it has 20
hair cutting lengths with one guard so
there's no drawer full of like all those
attachments which is so annoying it's so
messy
the pro kit is much more than just the
trimmer though it comes with their
dermatologist tested formulations for
post trim care so that includes
manscaped beer shampoo and conditioner
beard oil beard bomb to moisturize style
and Shimmer his facial hair the pro
beard kit also comes with three gifts so
a beard brush comb and scissors to
ensure his beard is ready to impress and
the brand new weed whacker 2.0 offers
improved blades and skin safe technology
with a no tugging guaranteed it's never
been so painless to mind his manholes
get 20 off in free shipping with our
code toast at manscape.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
use our code toast perfect gift for the
guy in your life but then it also like
serves you which is just great we love a
self-serving gift today's episode is
also brought to you by Legacy box all
right I feel like Legacy box is a brand
I'm always getting DMS about like what
was that company what was that code
listen up do you have drawers full
storage full of old cassettes VHS
checking I grew up in the VHS era and
like for years we had these boxes in our
storage unit of like family memories of
like our Dad and us singing the Spice
Girls and like two years ago we finally
did Legacy box and it was the best thing
we ever did it is a super simple mail-in
service to have all of your video tapes
camcorder tapes film reels and pictures
converted to perfectly preserved digital
files Legacy box is the industry leader
and they have helped over a million
customers Safeguard their past
so it's a super easy uh system they will
mail you the mailing label you throw it
all in the Box put the label on and then
you will get emails throughout the
process of like oh you've arrived at the
warehouse oh your digitizing has started
it's on the way back they'll send you
emails the whole time because like they
know what they're you know preserving is
like really important to you and then
you get it back we got it on a thumb
drive you can get it on like on a bunch
of different times a bunch of different
types of things like the cloud or a DVD
we got a thumb drive it was the best
thing we ever did so Legacy box is
offering our listeners an incredible 50
off go to legacybox.com toast order
today to take advantage of the low price
and then send in your media whenever
you're ready so you don't have to do it
now but just get it with our code that's
legacybox.com toast there's never been a
better time to preserve your entire
collection of memories your family will
thank you it's a great gift and then
you'll also just be like the favorite
daughter or son
thank you Claudia welcome our fifth and
final Story the latest scand of all news
Ariana Maddox has finally spoken out
about the Scandal let me pull up my
notes I literally had notes from
yesterday's episode okay well first
we're gonna do scandival updates and
then an episode recap because there's
two things I want to talk about quickly
she put out a gorgeous picture of
herself saying hi where to begin I want
to express my most sincere gratitude for
the outpouring of love and support I've
received from friends family and people
I've never met in the last two weeks
when I felt like I couldn't even stand
you have all given me strength to
continue and see through My Darkest
Hours to say I have been devastated and
broken is an understatement however I
know I that I am not in this alone so
many of my closest friends are also
grieving this loss right now I'm so
[__] lucky to have the best support
system in the world and I hope I can
repay every single person for the love
you have show me what doesn't kill me
better run oh my God I was obsessed
Beyond with that final line I was just
saying I'm like I was like oh it doesn't
kill me makes me stronger and then I'm
like wait what doesn't kill me better
run I'm using that in perpetuity it's so
true it's so good it's so good so she's
doing well she looks amazing I think she
was at this wedding in Mexico this
weekend I think that's where this
picture is from Katie also said I'm
watching up inside that she's doing
remarkably well I think you know I'm
sure it's highs and lows and
the whole world rallying around her
definitely doesn't hurt yeah but I'm
glad that she I wasn't even waiting for
her to say anything but it's like nice
to hear from her you know agreed I
wasn't expecting to hear anything from
her I just honestly I wish her well like
I hope she's just doing well taking care
of herself she doesn't owe us you know
social media content but appreciative
appreciative then also I wanted to share
Kristen Dodie when on yes and she said
she can see why Tom Sandoval went for
quote [__] dumb Raquel Levis
she did not hold back all these podcasts
that are coming out there's so much I
have a lot of thoughts but first she
called Raquel dumb with no personality
and said that she can see why Tom
cheated on Ariana with her Ariana has a
backbone Raquel does not Raquel
validates everything that Tom needs to
be validated she claims that Raquel make
sand about Raquel 28 makes Sandoval 40.
important feel cool and talented
meanwhile she shaded her ex-boyfriend's
quote stupid band in his sequin pants
and his nail polish and his dumb
haircuts and the pedophile mustache for
[__] sake she told no laws no no lies
were told and I think that um
that tracks like you can understand why
Sandoval like he needs this validation
he's he's having a midlife crisis and so
choosing Raquel people are like so
Random Raquel no it really does make
sense she's very young that would make
him feel young she's not she doesn't
have like a crazy backbone she's not
gonna like stand up to him he's just
very go with the flow and he wants
someone who thinks the world of him and
Ariana's like constantly like bringing
him down to reality but weirdly Ariana
thought the world of him and supported
him blindly which is so shocking to me
and I can't understand it but I also was
thinking about like Tom and Kristen's
relationship and I felt like you know
I'm sure they started out in like a
normal relationship and Kristen said
like they should have broken up after
two years and then like they were in the
relationship like two years too long and
I feel like he likes his
Partners like when they're girls in the
not in a physical sense but like in a
mental sense and then like you become a
woman and like you're sure of yourself
and you stand up for yourself and you
don't see him through these rows because
they're colored glasses anymore so it's
on to the next and so Ariana's like a
few years younger than Kristin and she
was very like girlish about the way that
she liked him and now like Ariana's like
a full woman with a business and all
these things and like it's you are less
impressive no it's so you're so right
like once in his eyes once they become
equals he's out no like you are smaller
when you are standing next to someone
who is bigger but like when they are
small it makes you feel big no that's a
really so once again him being bad 40
going after 28 year old especially at
this stage in his life where he really
is looking for like especially as he's
getting older like I'm sure maybe when
he was younger he really drank believed
his own own and drank his own Kool-Aid
like it does make sense why not make
sense but
you can see a pattern of like why this
person is the way they are and also I
could see like Raquel she's finding her
feet even in the episode last night I
mean I don't know how she went from that
to making the worst decisions of a
person's life but like in a few years
she will
coming to her own too and honestly it
will happen again yeah no you're a
hundred percent right the episode last
night was so interesting
um
and I think it's important to know we
don't know for sure and Katie Maloney
was on watch Happens Live last night and
to be honest either she was like keeping
a lot of information or she knows
nothing because there's no way that she
knows nothing she was definitely
gatekeeping and the word on the street
because sheena's friend did a podcast
with another one of Raquel's friends and
they said that Raquel and Sandoval
started to gravitate towards each other
on guy's night right after Vegas but
then when Katie was asked she said like
she didn't know if in the show that it's
possible it's almost like she didn't
want to say she didn't want to say no
because then that makes her look her and
Lala look even worse on tonight's
episode I agree and it's like how do I
feel like I know when the affair started
and you don't you don't you have access
to every single person in the
relationship yeah so I really do believe
as of last night's episode they hadn't
started hooking up yet I am going to
judge last night's episode on its own
and then also through the lens of what I
already know but just watching last
night's episode I was floored and
actually Ben watched with me and Ben I
was trying to explain to Ben the
Dynamics and he didn't really understand
how like what Raquel did is like such a
betrayal and he was like I'm team Raquel
Justice for Raquel like if you just
watched the episode so that's somebody
who has no
alliances and you know what my I have so
many takeaways but my major takeaway is
Christina Kelly is the [__] worst
she's such a follower and she's such a
mean girl and I feel like my only
memories of her and Andy actually
brought it up on what shop inside which
I was grateful for was like dragging
sheena's wedding dress crop top making
so much fun of her because she wasn't
invited to the wedding it was like such
a mean girl thing to do and even last
night she like runs into the room she
start like everyone everyone was
responsible but like Christina Kelly was
just like eating it up she was like so
excited to be part of the cool girl crew
and she sees Raquel about her own
NightLight and she runs back into the
room and it's like she has a nightlight
and these girls are so hypocritical
literally Lala's laying there with her
blanket she brought from home no and I
saw a tweet that was like this girl is
going to clown on Raquel bringing a
nightlight and it was LaLa in bed with
her blanket in her bottle from when they
went to Mexico a few years which was
yeah but no I'm saying on this actual
trip Lala is laying in bed with
Christina Kelly with her Leopard blanket
she brings it to the house in havasua
yeah yeah I'm like these are hunchbacks
who can't see their own the whole
episode was full of hunchbacks saying
Lala saying I respect relationships she
doesn't feel like Raquel respects
relationships when Lala was with Randall
when he was married and it's like okay
maybe Lala didn't believe that he was
married but every single person around
you knew he was married but you're the
closest one to it and you don't see that
he's married and slept with James while
he was with Raquel like I I I feel like
all those things are in the past and we
can move on from them but then that
doesn't make you the expert holier than
that on relationship respect you know
yeah so let's go through the episode
because they're in Vegas they get back
from this night Raquel is drunk which is
quite literally what they went on the
trip to do no literally and it made me
sad even though like on a drinking level
I do relate more to Lala and I think
Christina Kelly she's very pregnant now
yeah so I think she's pregnant on the
trip yeah she didn't drink at all
everything was like a club soda water
um so we have two sober people Katie
drinks but like she's clearly you know
manages it and Raquel is like in Vegas
single Lynn the prime of her life
drinking and like she wasn't even like
that crazy for like what she came in and
with a plate of food and this is like
the craziest thing you've ever seen oh
dramatic everyone was being and so mean
and I didn't even think what she said to
Lala was that mean especially given they
kept Lala kept like telling everyone the
story of what Raquel said and she's just
glazing over what Lala said like I told
her I wouldn't be comfortable like you
know around my man which is such a mean
thing to say right it ended up being
true but still in that moment it's not
true and so they're like and isn't that
so crazy what Raquel responded it's like
well you said was also like kind of
crazy yeah and it all stems from like
Raquel being over all over Oliver which
is like Lolly to do give did you give
her express permission or did you not
right right are you upset that she
hooked up with Oliver or are you not and
you can't be like somewhere in the
middle
you literally told her to go and do it
and then you're like treating her poorly
because she did it no last night's
episode was literally Raquel's villain
origin story like she's standing outside
that hotel oh my God that literally I'm
gonna be so sad Ben was like bereft he
was like that is so sad it was so sad
and honestly she should have left the
next day I was so surprised that she
didn't but it's almost like she had
drunk anxiety and she believed them
about what they were saying but they
were like gaslighting her into saying
she was crazy she took her heels off in
the hallway literally who hasn't done
that in Vegas she ate food and she went
to bed like she made out with one guy
who she knows like they work at the same
facility like what's the big [__]
deal no there's what was I missing that
was so embarrassing and crazy and no
wonder she had a panic attack with her
drunk anxiety but that panic attack
scene was so [__] real part of me
thought for a moment that she had maybe
already slept with Sandoval and so like
all of this anxiety drunk anxiety and
then this big secret caused her to have
the panic attack but I really don't
believe they had slept together yet but
that was a real [__] scene and they
literally got Gaslight her into a panic
attack and I think when they all saw she
started to freak out they decided to
like let up a little bit but then they'd
go to dinner that night and the whole
conversation again with Charlie Charlie
is a real one she's a real friend she's
so funny she has brass balls that you
know what she speaks facts she wants to
take on Lala Katie and Christina Kelly
like and she's not even a cast member
and she she's not doing it in like an
attention-seeking way and I was just
glad in that moment this episode
isolating it and isolated I was glad
that Raquel had someone in her Corner
because like lala just and Jane I was
really glad that James said this in his
interview because it's true Lala just
doesn't like Raquel and so it's just not
fair to invite someone on this really
intimate girls trip and then be with
your two best friends who you're
literally going to be giggling with in
Slumber partying and showering with and
having this one person that you're
treating other it's not nice you know
what the trip really needed Sheena yeah
well she knows the worst oh my God she
was being the worldiest vote last night
like so cringe first of all it really
wasn't a divorce celebration party no
when she said that I was like what the
[__]
no it was like a single girls trip so
another way no but there was a Schwartz
pinata yeah I guess you're right you're
right but Sheena was just being like a
[__] starting poster [__] starting if
she says get your shorts back one more
time I'm going to vomit I'm going to
vomit and I'm gonna put it in a box I'm
gonna send it to her house I feel like
vomiting I literally was cringing but
she clenched I can't hear it again turdy
Lou hold on I'm just reading my notes
because I had a lot oh and so the
overall you know takeaway from the
episode was like la la my God is this
Hunchback who can't see her own hunch
you're so she's allowed to [__]
Raquel's boyfriend and I know she
doesn't want anyone to say it but she
was a mistress she's allowed to do both
of those things nobody is allowed to be
affected by it nobody's allowed to talk
about it but she's afraid of Raquel
being around someone's man and I know
how that sounds given what we know but
I'm just saying isolated episode in this
moment like lala was being insane last
night and I feel like this whole time
she's kind of been like so real that's
why we really love her it's like yeah
she doesn't have these crazy alliances
to people like she just says what she
feels no and like she speaks the facts
and like she even says like a hard truth
sometimes but then last night she was
saying I hate the label mistress because
it doesn't get like put any
accountability on him it's like no no he
should be accountable but like yeah by
the way the word mistress doesn't put
any accountability on Randall but it
doesn't change the fact that she was a
mistress right it like it kind of does
it means that Randall had a mistress
which is like a [__] up thing to do no
and like lala speaking for women like
you don't speak for me like because you
were being crazy no and like I just it
really bothered me it's like okay well
Randall's not on the show how how do you
want us to hold his feet to the fire
right now like you're the one having
this conversation like right like it
somehow became a fight between Raquel
and Lala and Lala has no legitimate
gripes against Raquel Katie does and I
actually do agree like Katie has been
pretty gracious like inviting her on the
trip and I do feel like they could work
it out and get to a place but like this
whole Lala thing just like blew up and
separated Raquel from this group and
it's so Random yeah like in the battle
between Katie and Raquel Raquel is in
the wrong in the battle between Lala and
Raquel Lala is in the wrong but then
Lala uses Katie's arguments against yeah
Kell and it's like that's not what we're
talking about right now not fair and
then Christina Kelly is just there like
eating it all up being a mean girl yeah
it was such a hard episode to watch and
I was so grateful for Charlie and I've
never really particularly likened to
Charlie like I I just I didn't think she
was right for the show but you know what
she spoke [__] facts last night I
feel like when she first came on the
show she tried a little too hard and it
yeah read wrong and now that she's not a
full-time cast member she comes to the
things because she's either friends with
these people or she's not there because
she's not like she's just being herself
and she has nothing to lose and only
things to gain by saying the stuff
that's like funny and true and I think
that's a good position to be in when
Raquel and Charlie came out and said
that they were leaving and they were
like we're gonna go see Schwartz that
was like the the dagger of this Century
like that's the only thing no it's like
do you not value your life no I know but
you know what it's like this group has
really
like mocked her endlessly this whole
weekend and yes in the Raquel and Katie
scenario Raquel is wrong but like it was
just such a good way to go it's like oh
you've been like up my ass non-stop
attacking me this whole trip Schwartz
dagger like yeah it was kind of the
perfect exit and she she had some good
lines last night but she's not sure of
herself so she like shakes when she
delivers her supposed Jabs yeah it's
hard but I'm glad to at least see her in
this instance like standing up for
herself and even if she's not the most
eloquent like she's saying what we're
all thinking which is like lala how dare
you say this about me like it it took
her words but she's again for 24 hours
she should have said it in bed in Vegas
but she was drunk and she just felt so
bad you know the feeling it's like I'm
just so sorry like okay yeah I'm a
little bit miffed about this but I'd
rather you not be mad at me than me be
mad at you right now but it was like
this elephant in the room
yeah I don't I wouldn't trust you with
my man well I shouldn't have trusted you
with my man and by the way you're right
Lala just doesn't like Raquel and she
really was just like extra pissed about
the Oliver thing because when you stem
when you like follow that
storyline it's like James chose Raquel
all those years ago like James and
Rocket James and Lala like have
something weird they do but don't you
think if Lala ever called James one day
and said like I want to be your
girlfriend he would break up with
whoever he was dating yeah yeah but I
just think like she feels this like
protectiveness over James in a weird way
she does they are ride or die for each
other they came on the show together
like they
and that's like a different Alliance
that throws another wrench like because
when then Raquel went to boys night and
it's like on this in this instance we
are are on Raquel's side but it's like
Raquel has an enemy there James who's an
ally of Lala I was like oh [__] Raquel
there's just traps everywhere so then
boys Night Comes um nothing really
happens sheena's just being like pick me
energy and then the girls show up in the
episode ends and people are like trying
to glean like oh my God Sandoval knew
she was coming look at his smile and
look the way he's looking at her I
didn't really see anything like that was
that telling
um however now what looking at the
episode through the lens of what we
currently know a lot of it is you know
eerily foreshadowing
yes
but I don't know at that time I really
don't know if I would have said Raquel I
wouldn't trust you with my man like I
just think that was like a low blow of
Lala that happened to be true you know
yes agreed on Lala but Katie said in her
interview and this wasn't this was
before she knew anything she's only
Raquel's only interested in like people
her friends are interested in or people
her friends have dated so that was the
prettiest astute observation but also
like you guys are like just swimming in
the same fish tank all the time like
where else is she supposed to go not
saying that she should go to Sandoval
but like
um you know even like so they're filming
at this like forlorn empty club and
Oliver's there and they're single and
he's cute like and he's also like a part
of the Bravo Universe like yeah like
like she's not the type that's just
gonna I guess that's because she's not
the type that she's outgoing like the
way that Lala went up to those guys
Raquel could never no could never but
then I also felt like Raquel like lala
going up to these guys like she was just
like working so hard to try and prove
something because she got called out
like two hours earlier for not being
able to like land a man and honestly
like I found her her behavior to be like
a little desperate yeah it's true and
then like they were at this like kind of
weird [__] bar and they're like this
is so fun like it wasn't no they did
their best because the episode could
have turned into like okay the two fun
girls left in like the three boring
ladies are like alone and like Havoc
like what are they doing in Lake Havasu
the three of them they really did their
best to look like they were having fun I
wasn't buying it two of them are sober
right
um what is going on and because he's
like in a relationship so it's only two
single girls
they did a good job you know they swam
yeah yeah they got on the float
you know they had like a group combo
like we can't come off looking like
losers everybody getting like yeah and
then they went to that bar then I'm sure
that's the last place they wanted to go
on earth right no and then they like hug
out with the guys on the boat next to
them who were like for Lauren as well
like it was
it could have been a lot sadder even
when Charlie and Raquel were there the
trip felt Bare Bones and like random and
weird and then once they left and
they're doing the pinata it was even
worse even worse and when Charlie and
Raquel were there they only went to
dinner like well Charlie and Raquel went
out which I loved for them right right
that was like it's so crazy because like
the scandival notwithstanding like I
would weirdly be like riding for Raquel
like I actually thought she really held
her own in last night's episode and she
was unequivocally wronged by these girls
like they were bullies they were
Hypocrites but now knowing what we know
how do we move forward for real because
I'm like I am not on everyone else's
team yeah I agree I'm just gonna let the
season play out I I don't know how I
could ever get to I could never get to a
place where it's like we went from this
to seven month affair with the sand of
all that I would ever possibly
understand I know but
I said last week like I have no idea who
Raquel is we all just thought she was a
dumb [__] like maybe she's just like
this evil plotting person I don't know
who she is still she doesn't know who
she is she literally said the same thing
from the episode it was so sad oh my God
and the stuff about like James and her
parents and it made me really sad
because I I feel like it finally made
sense like why they broke up and why she
was still so devastated that they broke
up because it's like she would have
wanted to be with James and marry him
like she got engaged to him but you
cannot stay with someone who would say
such things about your parents she broke
up with him because she had to not
because she wanted to right and like
that's heartbreaking and then that
person is in another relationship in six
weeks yeah no it's that was shocking
your dad is miserable because he's
married to your fat mom like I my jaw
Hit the Floor James is the [__] word
I know and then it's like that's the
James Susan's like delivering like you
know bangers yeah I know later in the
episode like he is the worst alive human
being yeah
it's just been a crazy like this episode
this episode was a wrench
it was I I enjoyed it though I enjoyed
it I enjoyed the conflicting feelings I
thought I would like die because you
know what sometimes things aren't and
never will I condone what they did by
the way but sometimes things are not so
linear black and white yeah you know um
I thought last night's watch up inside
was going to be like tea spilled because
every time one of them goes on a podcast
it's like TTT Katie gave nothing I was
like and she someone asked her a
question that was like really good she
was like we'll have to wait to the
reunion like come on and he asked her
and it's like if Andy's asking you it
means you're allowed to say I feel like
Danny Pellegrino was like this is
[__] yeah there was nothing not a
drop honestly I stayed up so late to
watch because I got home late cause I
was out and I was pissed I was like 30
minutes of sleep that yeah it was
useless there was nothing if you haven't
seen it yet you don't need to watch it
like it was really giving nothing yeah
so that's your pump rules recap that was
your episode tomorrow is our last
episode of the week I'm gonna miss you
guys over the weekend but love y'all
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the Millennium Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast we found Spotify iTunes
District public video I already castbox
all the places five star review about a
beautiful stunning smart and wickedly
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing Thursday enjoy the latter half
of the week and we'll see you tomorrow
love ya bye